all restaurants in Cuba are owned by the
government starting a few years ago they
started having something called pala
Darth which means families can have
their own restaurant and told there's
one in his building
[Music]
this is pretty amazing I think the first
two floors are just basically a ruin
[Music]
all right this is Enrique Nunez and
Enrique this is your paladar is that
right that's right thank you so much for
having me no HS gracias it's my pleasure
I was born and raised eating the best in
this building
wait a minute you were born and raised
in this build yes that's fantastic is
that a cat out there that's yelling yeah
gods but what the heck who threw a plate
exams right brain fun that's baseball
yeah no I'm saying Hong Kong that was a
home run
yes yeah absolutely well I think they
hit the cat cuz thats quiet now
it'll gato is wealthy funny in any
language we have our mojitos can we look
around
sure these people over here I guess
that's Jesus on the left is that correct
yes you're right hey so sweet oh you
know this who this guy Pedro Flores
Jesus Christ and this is Karl Marx yeah
that's incredible because I don't think
Marx was a big fan of religion
oh my goodness Beyonce yes Oh J figure
and jay-z yeah Kevin Spacey right there
yes know me okay shirt unbuttoned a
little too low Kevin Spacey
oh is this Gerard Depardieu yeah that
guy's insane he's the one that smashed
the first two floors of the building it
looked fine before he showed up there's
Jack Nicholson yeah wearing sunglasses
in a paladar at night oh my god Rob
Schneider roughs neither so I'm
literally the last celebrity to come
here
[Music]
this food is so good I'm starting to
forget that I'm alone
Enrique I want to thank you you're
paladar is the best this was an
authentic Cuban experience the food was
magnificent your hospitality fantastic
you have pictures here of many stars but
I think it's time that you had a
photograph
[Applause]
I'm coming back in a year to see if it's
still there do not throw it out what's
wrong but I think he's gonna throw it
out
you